british politics has involved its fair
share of weirdness in the last few years
but eyebrows were still raised this week
when this happened
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that was sir ed davey the lib dem
leader knocking down a fake blue wall
after his party overturned a
big conservative majority to win the
cheshium and amisham
by-election mr davey says the lib dems
are on the march and gunning for other
seats in the so-called tory blue wall
but how realistic is that ambition let's
ask her davey
he joins us now
sir ed um stunning result in cheshium
and damascum 25
swing in the famous words of one of your
predecessors
um are you preparing for government yet
look this is a huge moment for the
liberal democrats it's
a big moment in british politics and for
british people i think up till
we defeated the conservatives in
cheshire people thought boris johnson
couldn't be beaten
that he was somehow impregnable now they
know he can little democrats show that
boris johnson
could be beaten and i've i've noticed
how people are smiling more today i
think there's a glimmer of hope
uh that the conservatives can be beaten
the liberal democrats are going to do
that
uh in any safe uh conservative seat
particularly on the blue wall
seats uh we are gunning for them that's
right
i i love the idea that the whole country
is um
is smiling at this victory just in time
for the summer solstice but
seriously we didn't see anything as as
big as or dramatic as this swing in the
elections last
month so presumably you must accept that
there are local factors
hs2 the planning issue that really
contributed to this size of swing
there are always some local factors but
actually on the doorsteps and i went to
cheshire mansion 16 times i talked to
hundreds of of people and the feeling i
got from them was they've been taken for
granted by the conservatives
many people on the doorstep said i was
the first politician to knock on their
doors and they'd live there for 20 30
years
so people not just in cheshire and amish
but across
the blue wall seats i think have been
taken for granted
and they saw liberal democrats listening
to them responding to them
and one of the things i heard was they
felt that boris johnson wasn't in tune
with traditional
conservative values and they were
worried about a whole range of
national issues as well so you know
i'm confident that we are seeing a
change in british politics
much bigger than people had been seeing
i think that both the pandemic and the
polls have
have not have not picked this up um and
there can be big shifts in british
politics we saw it in scotland
when the labour monopoly went we've seen
it in the north of england with
the conservatives on the march i think
the blue wall in the south can be
can be taken uh by the liberal democrats
uh in
in large numbers of constituencies let's
see if those
those high expectations um which
frankly we've heard before can actually
be fulfilled and you talk about
you know talking to people on the
doorstep um what will the liberal
democrats
leaflet at a general election say will
they say
as your candidate did in cheshire and
amisham
we are totally opposed to hs2
or will they say as you have said in the
house of commons
we support hs2 as an essential
aspect of development of this country
well if you remember cheryl gillan who
sadly died and triggered this
by-election
she opposed hs2 on behalf of her
constituents in cheshire
she fought boldly against her own party
the conservative party who railroaded it
through
um i think it's completely reasonable
for sarah green wanting to be the
representative for cheshire to have an
independent voice
but let's be clear trevor um
high-speed links because it's important
to get more capacity on our always it's
important to invest in public transport
for climate change but that doesn't mean
we have to accept the way the government
are implementing hs2 the way the hs2
company
is going about things because they're
not listening to people in cheshire and
amazon they're not
that we felt on the doorsteps again that
they were being taken for granted
by the department for transport and by
the hs2 company
david though i mean it's not like you've
got hundreds of mps you've
you know you haven't got that many to
have different factions within
where will you stand when you come to a
national
contest are you as a party going to be
for hs2
or are you not going to be for hs2 well
listening trevor the hs2 legislation has
passed
parliament uh it's impossible to have
another vote in it a certain next few
years
what is before parliament is a planning
bill
and um both with hs2 and the planning
bill and many other things
the conservatives have been taking
people for granted haven't been
listening
and the planning bill and the proposed
planning reforms which are
frankly a developer's charter well what
what the vast majority of people were
concerned about
in cheshire mammals because they're
worried that and on yet another
environmental issue
the government is saying one thing and
doing another not listening to local
people
okay let's clear up um something that
seems to have emerged in the last couple
of days
liberal democrat path to government as
your predecessor nick clegg showed
probably lies through some kind of
alliance or arrangement or understanding
with a larger party
you could reach an uh an understanding
with labour not a form of pact
but you don't contest seats where one of
you can't
win are you up for that well i thought
it was interesting cheshire mamasham
lots of labandi green voters saw liberal
democrats not only
just the best party to beat the
conservatives
but also liked our policies and
therefore
you know i think it's uh we shouldn't
take voters for granted should we
um i don't think political parties own
their voters and can't tell them which
way
uh to go you know i'm interested in
arguing for progressive
uh policies that are in tune with uh
people
in britain and i'm determined to make
sure that we win in those areas where we
really are
competitive and we showed how
competitive we are in cheshire
management and actually in the local
elections
before that just last month and we took
control of oxfordshire and
cambridgeshire
uh councils for the first time we made
big gains in hertfordshire and surrey
and wiltshire
this i think gives credence to this
argument about the blue wall
that the liberal democrats can make
advances against the conservatives in
that
and i think it would just be wrong
trevor to be honest to say
uh that people can't have a chance to
vote for a liberal democrat candidate or
indeed a chance to vote for a labor
candidate
yeah but we know what we but we know
what this is real politics
um and i'm i'm detecting i'm detecting
the sense that
you're not going to be tremendously
upset if
you as a party decide that you're going
to concentrate your efforts
in areas where you can win and where the
labour party
is more likely to beat the tories than
you are
that you might decide that you're not
going to
uh throw all your eggs into that
those particular baskets this is not
formal
but are we saying that we are in that
kind of territory
trevor i think yeah the uh the audience
to this program will be surprised to
hear you say that it's somehow unusual
for parties to go after areas where they
can win um
you know you we don't have a huge amount
of results no but you don't need not
where you can't win i'm saying that the
liberal democrats under my leadership
will be a campaigning party we will go
out there and campaign for every vote
but we'll use our resources wisely
first-past-the-post system it's dreadful
we want proportional representation we
want electoral reform but until we get
that we've got to play with the current
system
and that requires you to to concentrate
your
resources in areas where you're well
placed to beat the incumbent and that's
for the liberal democrats that's
almost entirely beating conservatives
so that's right davey thank you very
much indeed thank you